money wins you're corrupt and so is the
world you were only with me to get to
power oh their whole relationships is
such a disaster my name is Douglas
Bonaparte I'm a certified financial
planner today I'm gonna break down the
finances of the characters in the show
secession
I was just talking to my mom she said
apparently he'll leave me 5 million
anyway so I'm golden baby it's actually
a very bad financial planning concept to
think that there's going to be a
windfall in the future when you really
don't have an idea as to when how much
or having any control over that
whatsoever you can't do anything with
five Greg five's a nightmare this is the
best part is it oh yeah can't retire
not worth it to work now let's say Greg
inherits five million dollars today
generally speaking inheritance from
family members or anyone from that
matter is received tax free well how
much can Greg live on without running
out of money the three percent rule is a
convenient rule of thumb because it
demonstrates what we could at least get
out of a sum of money by investing it
prudently so three percent of five
million dollars would give Greg about a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year now that's a pretty good living by
anyone's standard but he's sitting in
his great uncle's 63 million dollar
penthouse on Fifth Avenue and he appears
to be drinking a bottle of blend and
Single Barrel if this is the lifestyle
that Greg has become accustomed to five
million dollars isn't going to cut it
great do you think we could figure this
out you want to transfer now it's 40K
here's the thing if that's a stainless
steel Submariner nowhere near forty
thousand dollars but what about watches
being a good investment yes there are
some watches out there that do
appreciate in value over time will Greg
make out well with his forty thousand
dollar investment in this watch time
will tell but you'll probably do better
investing in the U.S stock market if I
try to say the truth my favorite
interaction between the two of them I
think period so I love this one all my
life
I've been thinking a little bit about
money in the scene where Tom tells shiv
that he often thinks about money he's
really laying out his financial
background we know his mother is so
highly respects his attorney in the Twin
Cities and a job like that probably
earns anywhere from 180 000 to 250 000 a
year Far Cry from billionaire status
well this is delicious wow I'm very glad
you like it because it cost a pretty
penny this whole scene is a great way of
showing the disparity between the
backgrounds that both shiv and Tom come
from if you're wondering what the venue
costs where Tom and jiv are getting
married well we looked it up it's about
nineteen thousand dollars for two days
Logan owns this castle and therefore has
to not only maintain it but upkeep it we
see a scene in a room we got Priceless
pieces of art we can only begin to
imagine how much this Castle actually
costs come on is there something wrong
with his body it's just suits is he
wearing a suit in that scene you look
like a divorce attorney from the Twin
Cities I don't put it past Tom to spend
some money on a suit he says he really
likes his suit maybe spent six hundred
dollars to a thousand dollars had it
tailored looks good for most people
that's an expensive suit we see Tom
upgrade his career into becoming the
head of ATN where he should have no
issues affording any type of suit that
he wants custom off the rack designer
whatever it may be it's a really really
nice place thank you thanks and he'll
get to keep it in the divorce so in
season four we learned that Tom and jiv
may get divorced it brings up a great
question how are the assets going to be
divided so when we think about the
assets in most people's lives that could
get split up during divorce it comes
down to things like their retirement
accounts checking accounts and the
family home we have a feeling that they
live in lower Manhattan in an apartment
that costs at least 5.8 million dollars
if Tom and shiv do get divorced a prenup
which we know Tom likely has signed
comes into play and that will spell out
exactly what he does or does not yet
it says that the prenup is a little uh
unconscionable oh hold it that means it
has to be so bad and so not in Tom's
favor for a lawyer to use that term but
uh she did notice that three uh
infidelities there's no yeah we don't
need to do that it is common to see
infidelity Clauses in prenups but
whether two people should enter into a
prenup that's really about what's right
for them you want to have a sense of how
they value money what possessions or
assets that they have are truly theirs
all the top attorneys are conflicted out
conflicted Out means that there's a
conflict of interest with that attorney
representing her spending a lot of money
on an attorney doesn't always guarantee
good results but look you usually get
what you pay for here I can't help but
to have this feeling that shiv will be
okay and it's really Tom that's going to
be you know working hard to figure out
what he's entitled to if anything at all
I'm one of the executors of your dad's
Affairs in season four Logan's death is
the main event that ultimately sets off
the name of the show secession and it
appears at a certain point
undated
it was suggested that it was your dad's
wish that okay Kendall take over a CEO
okay so classic there's a coda Soul here
that's an amendment to a will or a legal
document this is actually pretty common
he underlined recently
underlined or
crossed out this only emphasizes the
need to have clear communication with
those you're putting in charge of
handling your estate to ensure that this
doesn't happen to you it's probably good
form to make sure that all estate
planning documents are in one place and
if you are working on any changes to
communicate what those potential changes
might be so you don't catch anyone off
guard like Logan here clearly is what
else is in the can you I don't want a
music burial in the city Catholic we're
not just talking about assets the things
that you own we're also talking about
children and for more advanced estate
planning cases you have trusts or trust
being born out of the well he's got like
a ton of investment impressionisms right
like he's got uh three gigans no unseen
for tax reasons and then you hear about
three Gogan paintings and those
paintings can fetch more than a hundred
million dollars so what's the tax
planning around this likely so that
those assets are excluded from the
estate that there would not need to be a
state tax paid on that generally
speaking is never a bad idea to have
your basic estate planning documents in
place this is your last will and
testament Powers of Attorney healthcare
proxy and a living will
here in the show we really do get our
first Glimpse at what Kendall might
actually be worth most of these shares
probably have a very low basis meaning
they were gifted a long time ago which
means a significant portion of that sale
is going to be capital gains you might
as well take about a third of that gain
off the table for the tax man
so in this scene we have Kendall going
to an investor meeting and unboxing a
pair of sneakers from long fall and he
wants to show off that he's got great
style walking into a meeting now I'm
under the impression that Kendall is
spending his own money to look the part
some could argue is he taking a
deduction to wear these clothes because
it has something to do with work now
typically that's reserved for uniforms I
wouldn't go quite calling a pair of long
Von sneakers a uniform however computers
Transportation meals and expenses wages
these are all very very typical things
that get written off as part of
deductions
in this scene you get a really good look
at how the Roy family in this case
Kendall likes to travel this Helicopter
Company can take you from Manhattan to
The Hamptons for about four thousand
dollars plus taxes which if you are
asking the question is that deductible
probably so when it comes to deducting
expenses for business purposes there's
usually not a limit on the quality of
things but there are certain threshold
percentage of income or Revenue that
would create what's called an audit risk
and while Roman might not be visibly as
fancy as his brother Kendall he clearly
too likes to travel in style and comfort
on his private jet costing about sixteen
thousand dollars an hour to Charter and
we see Roman pull up in two Chevy
Suburbans which would run about eight
hundred dollars a day to rent in
Manhattan Logan created this Empire and
he clearly was set out to leave this to
his children but his children are so
affected that he might not actually get
to see his own wishes for them be
carried out and this is all very typical
in situations where we're talking about
business enterprises being passed down
through family members
[Music]